second thing you mentioned was was you
know ceos are kind of crazy and and you
kind of
even skimmed a little bit over that
what's interesting is
bipolar disorder and you mentioned kind
of some of those traits i talked about
entrepreneurs
i read a list of 11 traits that describe
and every entrepreneur for the most part
9 out of 10 goes yep that's me yep
that's me yep that's me
it's a 9 10 or 11 of the 11 trades what
are those rates
because i know i i botched that list for
you yeah i can i can read them out loud
if you want me to read them out loud go
ahead yeah um so
but what these traits actually are is
traits that describe
every entrepreneur and when i read out
the list and everyone identifies with it
then i give them the rest of the story
so here's the 11 traits and anybody
listening can count on their fingers
and and see if you get at least over
five
are you often filled with energy does
your mind get flooded with ideas
are you driven are you restless
are you unable to keep still are you
often working on little sleep
do you get euphoric are you easily
irritated
by minor obstacles do you burn out
periodically
do you act out sexually which is like
flirting or massage parlors or anything
like that
do you feel persecuted by those who do
not accept your vision
so that's 11 traits how many do you have
oh i got them all
yeah i'm 11 i'm 11 for 11. by the way on
the traits for
attention deficit disorder i have 17 of
the 18 signs for adv as well
where we are though on those traits is
those are not just traits of
entrepreneurs
those are actually the clinical diagnose
traits for bipolar disorder
so most entrepreneurs are on the
spectrum for bipolar if you said yes to
10 or 11 of the traits you'd actually be
diagnosed and medicated
for bipolar bipolar disorder has been
nicknamed by the medical community as
the ceo disease
so most entrepreneurs have those traits
in fact the way that i met the ceo of
sprint we were sitting on a plane
and i diagnosed him as having um add
bipolar and being on the spectrum for
tourette's because he had a nervous tic
he's like how do you know this about me
and i said i just know entrepreneurs
better than anybody and you are
massively add in bipolar
and he was he had just built a billion
dollar company that he'd sold the
softbank
and was getting ready to go over and
become the ceo of sprint and here i am
telling them he's crazy but
the medical community thinks
entrepreneurs are nuts we're actually
just hardwired to be very different
from doctors and teachers and engineers
and one of the hardest struggles for
entrepreneurs that i've recognized over
the years is
we're struggling with being told that
we're there's something wrong with us
we're struggling with being told we have
a disease bipolar
is not a disorder it's actually a
strength
the mania that crazy energy
the starting things quickly the fact
that we get bored and delegate quickly
those are all perpetual motion machines
that help us start our company and get
it going
the stress and depression is simply us
burning out and course correcting and
working too much
and feeling bad about taking time off
for our business because of the guilt of
talking to our employees
but that's a but and it's magnified for
us the stress is magnified
because we can't go tell our spouse or
our friends oh we're not taking a
paycheck for three months we're not
paying ourselves
we haven't paid ourselves back for
expenses you know here we are recruiting
some some vp
to come and work for us even though
we're not sure how we're going to meet
payroll in six days
you know like we're really magnified
amount of stress
so that that craziness is um is is
another reason to be involved in
mastermind groups and
and conferences for entrepreneurs and
coaching even
so that you are around your tribe of
people that aren't going to wallow in it
but learn from it and then grow from it
you